seems like only yesterday my mother said
to me
the ugliest thing in the world
is a naked man with socks on
[Applause]
can you believe that was the first piece
of sex advice i ever received
i was 11 years old growing up in kenya
and i believe this might have been my
mother's way of trying to scare me out
of having intimate relationships with
men
it didn't
instead
i became fascinated by sex
i wanted to hear other people's stories
about sex and watch all the movies with
all the sex scenes
everything about this
very taboo subject was so intriguing to
me
well now my mom's gone
nine years this year
and true to her word
the ugliest thing in the world is a
naked man with socks on
but over time i have found things to be
far much uglier
it took me a ton of therapy to realize
that my fixation with sex was due to a
traumatized childhood
see
i was sexually assaulted when i was
eight years old
and i never told anybody
because even in my comedic sex advice
household
i still didn't learn about consent
and i was afraid
afraid that i would get into trouble
afraid that it was my fault or that
nobody would believe me
or worse still
afraid that my parents would ground me
forever
and i'm not alone
men sexually assault women and girls on
a massive rate in kenya where 45 of
women aged between
15 and 49 have reported either physical
or sexual violence
actually only 14 percent have reported
sexual violence and this is possibly
because
most of this violence happens in
domestic partnerships
where the perpetrator is known by the
victim
and these patents play out all around
the world
and i truly believe
that it's a lack of sex education in
schools that is partially to blame
back home
the education system is one of
destroying your relationship with self
shaming you for your discovery
and then praising you for how much you
conform
this
coupled with disturbing imagery of
ailing genitals
is aimed at teaching us one thing
to abstain from all sexual activity
the perfect puritanical society
but of course young people are still
having sex
they just don't understand the
consequences of their adults like
choices
this too was my experience
i had zero resources growing up
and unfortunately often found myself in
less than favorable situations as a teen
and a young adult
add on to that coming out as a queer
woman
in a very homophobic country
therapist once jokingly said that i
needed to pick a struggle
all of this is to say
i really want to create
a better
transition process for young people
because i truly believe
that the more we talk about sex
the safer and the better it'll be for
everybody
[Music]
so in 2016 i started a sex positive
podcast called the spread
targeted at a pan-african audience
i really wanted to create a safe space
where young people could openly talk
about different aspects of their
sexuality without feelings of shame
or judgment
and it turns out
people love to talk about sex
and i've had the great pleasure and
honor of answering a myriad of these
questions about sex on my podcast
such as my boyfriend says that if we
have sex and it's my first time and
without a condom that i won't get
pregnant is this true
of course it's not true
having sex without a condom poses great
risk of not only getting pregnant but
contracting stis
or i watch too much porn and i'm no
longer aroused by my partner am i broken
no you're not broken
but too much porn can desensitize you
from real life pleasures
or
i'm 24 years old and my friends make fun
of me
because i'm a virgin should i have sex
just to gain popularity
absolutely not
first of all virginity is a social
construct
and i think you should have your sexual
debut
thank you
when you're good and ready to
a lot of the time
we have
a lot of fun on the podcast honestly but
sometimes it does get a little bit
serious
especially when it comes to one topic in
particular
consent
these are some of the questions i
receive
my husband insists on having sex with me
even when i don't want to i've relayed
my concerns he always responds with
you're my wife it's your place to do so
how do i prevent this from happening or
i went out last night and woke up this
morning next to the guy that was
chatting me up i have no idea what
happened but i think we had sex
what should i do
it's conversations like these that
reinforce the fact that people don't
have the first clue
how to talk about consent
so it's become my life's work
to create a curriculum to educate young
people on consent
now the inspiration for this might
surprise you
but
i got it in my 30s after a visit to a
bdsm dungeon
for those of you that don't know bdsm
is a series of practices in erotic role
play that involve
bondage
discipline dominance and submission and
sadomasochism
now i know a lot of people have a lot of
misleading information about the bdsm
community but more often than not we
create and curate safe spaces with an
array of toys and items for the kinky
community to play with if they so please
it's like a playground
for adults
in bdsm everything is negotiated before
it happens
and these are some of the rules and
regulations that would greet you upon
entry
one
do not touch anyone without asking
even a hug if you don't know somebody is
a bad move without permission
two
do not touch anyone's toys without
permission
if you're not sure if something is a toy
ask
three
consent can be withdrawn at any time
during an activity
and my personal favorite
if consent is not given
do not ask again
accept and respect and know as
graciously as you would oh yes
now
in no way am i interested in teaching
children bdsm
but bdsm a community that is created
strictly for adults that people view as
shameful and dangerous has better
guidelines for learning about consent
than
many homes or schools in many parts of
the world
and like you've heard these rules aren't
specifically sexual
but they can apply to sex
i truly think that the strategy
to raising adults with healthy sexual
behaviors
is to first teach kids about consent
like super early way before sex is even
a topic of conversation
can you imagine having conversations
with kids and
letting them know that everything about
their bodies can be negotiated
for example let them decide who they
want to help them during bath time
or
tell them that they don't have to accept
that kiss on the cheek from grandma
or tell them that they have to ask for
permission before they play with
somebody else's toy truck
and let them know that they can say
actually my pronouns are they them
without feeling guilty
it's these tools that will help keep our
children safe
and respect people throughout their
lives
we have the power to shape the future
the solutions are simple
it's the patriarchy that's so damn
difficult
so let's engage
five
six
or eight-year-olds
on conversation around consent
and bodily autonomy
as a function of affirming
their humanity
which in turn can look like adults
having
safe
healthy
pleasurable and fun sex
because consent
isn't just about sex
it's first about communication and
relationships
thank you